all they had was
two days warning seven villages in
nagorno-karabakh
suddenly added to the first lot of
territory that passed into azerbaijani
hands this friday
these are new villages built by
armenians displaced in the first war in
the early 1990s
now forced to move again burn the homes
they've built
rather than leave them to azerbaijan
pack up their things and even dig up
what's most precious to them
the despair here is unbearable
the family we meet on a windswept farm
robbed of everything they care about
why did they take our children and kill
them this woman says
i don't even know where my dead child is
to bring and bury
and then the misery of her son
my brother is dead my relative is dead
why should i
stay he says it would only take one
knife here
and that's it
in the village of noor maraga we meet
only men
the women and children fled at the start
of this six week war
in soviet times angelique bogosian lived
in azerbaijan
they were his friends but not anymore
armenia is trying to prevent that
sending busloads of refugees to the
region's capitals to panacurt
trying to pack its diminishing lands
with people
but the homeland they call atsach is
much smaller now
and armenia has lost most of the seven
azerbaijani districts around it which
had served as a buffer zone
kalbajar is one of those the deadline to
leave was extended last week
but when we drive through it's deserted
already in these contested hillsides
history has a habit of repeating itself
it's armenians who've abandoned these
villages now
but at the end of the last war this was
an azerbaijani area
it was the azerbaijanis who fled on mass
from the armenians who had won that war
the petrol station here is vandalized
and there's a message for the newcomers
if and when they come
keorgia milian keeps guard and directs
the traffic
he lives across the mountains in
nagorno-karabakh and he swears he'll
never leave
him
by
the reminders of past wars are
inescapable here as is the awful feeling
of more to come
[Applause]
dynamically sky news in nagorno-karabakh